Arkadaşlar merhaba. Ben Üfte Hoca. Tüm
9. sınıf öğrencilerime selam olsun.
Hocam artık anlatımlar Maarif Tadında.
Maarif model bizden ne istiyorsa o
arkadaşlar. Ve MEB kitaplarını birebir
tarayarak gidiyoruz. Bundan sonra
bambaşka anlatımlarla karşınızdayız. E o
zaman lafı hiç uzatmayacağız. Kanala
abone olalım arkadaşlar. Kanalımız 2
milyona doğru gidiyor. Beğenelim,
yorumları yağdıralım. Yüzlerce binlerce
yorum görmek istiyorum. Sonrasında
inşallah videoya geçelim. Ama sizden bir
ricam olacak arkadaşlar. Birazdan
göreceğiniz şablon hoşunuza gittiyse
yazın lütfen yorumlara hoşunuza
gittiğiniz. Ben o şablonla, o taslakla
devam edeceğim. Tamam. Sizden gelen
dönütlere göre şimdi birazdan
göreceğiniz ders anlatım şablonu. O
bilgilerin sunuluş şablonu hoşunuza
giderse o şekilde bundan sonraki bütün
videoları hazırlayacağım. Haberiniz
olsun. O konuda da bilgilerinizi
istiyorum, görüşlerinizi istiyorum. E o
zaman hiç vakit kaybetmeye gerek yok.
Arkamızı yastalım. Sözün inceliği
birinci tema. Haydi başlayalım. İlk şiir
bilgisi videosu gelsin. Evet, işte
Maarif tadında anlatım arkadaşlar.
Önümüzde bir şiir var ve bu şiirden yola
çıkarak konu, ana duygu, yazılış amacı,
imge ve çağrışım, sembol. Bu arada
bunlar sözün inceliği temasında 9. sınıf
Türk edebiyatı marif model sözün
inceliği temasında bilmeniz gereken
kavramlar arkadaşlar. Birazdan bu
kavramların ayrıntılı tanımları, detaylı
örneklerle geleceğiz. Çok net orada
konuşacağız ama öncelikle şu marif
modelin tadını bir çıkaralım arkadaşlar.
Kelime grupları, kelimelerin farklı
anlamda kullanımları, açık ve örtük
ileti, ahenk vesaire. Şimdi bunları
konuşacağız. Birazdan her şeye gireceğiz
ama önce şu şiiri bir okuyalım. Hocam
gitbahar, halde nuset zorluğan bir
okuyalım. Sonra bunları tek tek bula
bula bula bula gidelim. Bizden ne
istiyor? Ne yapmak istiyor hocam? Neleri
bulmamızı isteniyor? Onları tek tek
bulalım arkadaşlar beraber. Sonrasında
da bunların ayrıntılı anlatımlarıyla
karşınızda olalım. Bu şiir bilgisiyle,
şiirle ilgili ilk videomuz olacak.
Devamında söz sanatları var, vesaireler
var. Birçok şey bizi bekliyor. Şimdi git
bahar halde nüset zorlutun. Önce şiir
bir anlamlı bakalım hocam. Çekil bu
gölgeli yolda gezinme. Bahar bakışların
yine pek sarhoş. Yanılıp gönlüme misafir
inme. Kapısı kilitli mihrabı bomboş.
Mabettir orası meyhane değil. Işıklar
kokular sesler çiçekler. Ömrünün her
günü bir başka düğün. Bülbüller koynunda
açlı çiçekler. Güller dökülürler göğsüne
bütün. Gerçekten güzelsin. Efsane değil.
Altınlı başında papatya niçin. Sarı
saçlarına pembe gül takın. Git bahar
gönlümde ibadet için diz çöken kızları
ürkütme sakın kalbime girme. O kaşhane
değil git bahar git bahar. Uzaklarda gül
denize renginden bırak hediye. Ufuklarda
gezin semaya süzül. Kalbime sokulma
peymane diye. Bu arada üç noktayı şöyle
bir yapıştıralım hocam. Devamı var
şiirimizin ama biz bir kısmını aldık.
Şimdi hocam bir kısmına baktık biz bu
kısımdan. Öncelikle konuya bir bakalım.
Şöyle bir yaklaştırayım ben bunu bir.
Hatta uzaklaştırayım. Ha şöyle tatlı
tatlı gidelim. hakkını verelim. Şimdi
ilk adımımız konu. Şiirde ne
anlatılıyor? Şüphesiz ki burada sürekli
olarak bir işte gerçekten güzelsin var.
Kalbime girme var. Sürekli papatya işte
ne bileyim bahar, bahara sürekli bir
gönderme yaptı. Aslında baharın
güzelliği yazılabilir. Hiç fena olmaz.
Baharın
güzelliği konu olarak karşımıza geliyor
basit düzeyde. Peki ana duygu şiirde
baharı anlattı vesaire. Fakat ana
duygusu ne? Şiir bize hangi duyguları
hissettiriyor? İşte marif modelin bizden
tam olarak istediği bu. Yani sizin
düşünceleriniz arkadaşlar. Biz bu şiiri
okuduğumuz zaman her şeyden önce hani
git bahar var. Yani bir aslında içe
kapanma da var. Git diyor ya ben burada
yalnız kalacağım. Bir içe kapanma var
aslında. Çok net hissediyoruz. İçe
kapanmayı görüyorsunuz. Hüzün çok net
bir şekilde hissediliyor. Hüzün var, içe
kapanma var, alttan alta özlem var.
Değil mi? Biz bunları okurken buradan
bariz bir şekilde bunu hissediyoruz. Git
diyor yani bir içe kapanma var. Gel
demiyor. Bahar her şeyinle gel. demiyor.
Kendini aç, baharı bana yaşat demiyor.
Ne yapıyor? Git bahar, git bahar, git
bahar. Sürekli olarak bir içe kapanmayı,
özlemi, hasreti vesaireyi alttan alta
hissediyoruz. Peki yazılış amacı.
Yazılış amacı sadece şiiri okuduğun
zaman ulaşabileceğin bir şey gibi
görünse de şiirlerin alt şeyleri de var,
mesajları da var. Yani ben bu şiirin
yazıldığı döneme baksam, Halid Nusret
Zorlu Tuna'yı tanısam mesela kitapta
Faruk Nafız Çamlıbel'in hayatı
anlatılıyor biliyorsunuz web kitabında.
Orada neyi veriyor? sanat şiirini
veriyor. Siz Faruk Nafız Çamlıbe'in
hayatına baktığınız zaman aslında daha
öncesinde incelediğiniz sanat şiirinde
çok daha güzel detaylar hissediyorsunuz.
Ya diyorsunuz adam burada doğmuş ha o
yüzden burayı anlatıyor. Ha adam Anadolu
Anadolu'nun Şuşu köylerinde yaşamış. Ha
o yüzden burayı böyle anlatmış gibi çok
daha iyi anlıyorsunuz. Doğal olarak
Halid Üst Zorlu Turan'ın hayatını,
şiirin yazıldığı dönemi vesaireyi ele
almak lazım tabii bunu aktarmak için.
Onu da ben aktaracağım şimdi sizlere
arkadaşlar. Şair bu şiiri hangi amaçla
yazmış olabilir? Evet. Baharın
güzelliği. Eyvallah. Tamam. Şöyle yaptım
hocam. Baharın güzelliği eyvallah ama
artı artı artı sadece bunun için
yazmamış arkadaşlar. Aynı zamanda 1919
İstanbul'un işgali sırasında o yıllarda
İstanbul'un işgali sırasındaki vatani
duyguları da aslında alttan alta bu şiir
de vermeye çalışmış. Yani bir tarafta
baharın güzelliği vesairesi, gidişi
gelişi anlatılırken bir tarafta alttan
alta dönemin kesinlikle ama kesinlikle
içinde bulunduğu buhranı vesaireyi
anlatıyor. Cepte kalsın. İmge ve
çağrışım. Şimdi ben buradan ne görüyorum
hocam? Bir yandan da şöyle yanımda da
şiiri açtım arkadaşlar. Oradan da çize
bir de bunun çıktısını aldım ben size de
PDF olarak vereceğim. Ben de PDF'ini
aldım. Yanımda duruyor arkadaşlar
kağıtlar yanımda. Bu PDF'ten ben de
satır satır üzerine çizip yazarak
sizlerle birlikte götüreceğim. Şimdi ne
diyor mesela burada?
Bahar bakışların yine pek sarhoş. Şimdi
biz ne bulacağız? İmge ve çağrışım
bulacağız. Hangi imgeler dikkat çekiyor?
Sizlere neleri çağrıştırıyor? Bakın
burada baharın bakışları ifadesi çok net
bir imgedir arkadaşlar. Baharın bakışı
olur mu Allah aşkına? Yani soyut bir
şeyi adeta somut. Bahar bayağı bildiğin
insan Ahmet, Mehmet, Ayşe gibi bakıyor
diyor. Burada bariz bir şekilde
somutlaştırdığım net bir imge haline
getirdi. Mabettir orası vesaire. Kapısı
kilitli diyor mesela. Yanılıp gönlüme
misafir inme. Mesela gönüle misafir
olarak inmek de burada bariz bir şekilde
imge olarak karşımıza geliyor. Ya da
devamına baktığım zaman kapısı kilitli,
mihrabı bomboş. Bir yerlerde şey
geçiyor. Kalbime girme. Ah mesela
kalbime girme ifadesi de öyle. Sanki
kapıyı çalıp girmek gibi. Zorlarsak
onlarca burada mesela başka düğün düğün
kavramı da öyle. Burada zorlarsak bir
sürü imge ve çağrışıma ulaşmak mümkün.
Bu imgelerle bizde baharın gidişi ya da
baharın gitmesi gerektiği ya da baharın
getirdikleri gibi birçok şeyi
çağrıştırdı. Zihnimizde birçok anlam
yaşattı. Ama bütün mesele şu aslında.
Kişinin yaşanmışlığı kelimelere verdiği
anlamı da etkiliyor. Nerede
yaşıyorsanız, nasıl bir hayat
yaşıyorsanız, neler yaşamışsanız bunları
tabii ki kelimelere yüklemek mümkün. Bu
şiiri tabii ki kendi içerisinde sınırlı
görmek lazım. Ama buradaki imgeler
baharın bakışları, misafir inmek, kalbe
girmek ve daha birçok mesela hediye
bırakmak, denize renginden hediye bırak.
Bunların hepsi imgesel anlatım. Hocam
bakın dikkat. Burada sembole baktığımız
zamansa tabii ki şüphesiz ki bahar
olarak sembol karşımıza gelecek. Ama
sorusu ne? Diyor ki şiirde sembolik
anlam taşıyan unsurlar neler? Evet biz
baharı burada kesinlikle ele almalıyız
arkadaşlar. Bahar, gönül yani kalp gibi
de karşılanabilir. Bunlar şiirdeki
semboller. Nedir hocam? Sembol
genellikle arkadaşlar tek bir kavram.
Birazdan tanımını, detayını göreceğiz
ama genellikle tek bir kavram. Zaman
zaman kelime grubu olabiliyor ama
genellikle tek bir kavramla anlatılmak
istenen şey aslında gizli anlamların o
örtük anlamların birazdan konuşacağız.
Yüklendiği şey diyebiliriz. Sembol için.
Konu tamam. Ana duygu tamam. Bizde ne
hissettirdikleri ya ana düşüncesini
yazınız demiyor artık adam. Temayı yaz
demiyor. Bize ne hissettiriyor? İşte
bunu soruyor. Yazılış amacı çok önemli.
Kesinlikle sözün inceliği temasının bel
kemiği arkadaşlar cepte kalsın. İmge ve
çağrışım. Evet. Birçok şeyi imge olarak
alabiliriz. Zihnimizde uyandırdığı
çağrışımları yazabiliriz. Sembolysa
genellikle şiirin tamamında çoğu zaman
başlığında gizli olan birçok anlamın
yüklendiği kısım. O da tamam. Şimdi
geldik hocam ikinci kısma. Kelime
grupları, kelimelerin farklı anlamlarda
kullanılıp kullanılmaması, açık ve örtük
ileti ve şüphesiz ki ahenk. Bunları da
cebe koyarsak artık biz 1inci ünitede
almamız gereken şeyle ilgili genel
anlamsal boyutu halletmiş olacağız
arkadaşlar ki daha söz sanatları vesaire
bekliyor. Geleceğiz. Şimdi kelime
grupları noktasında aşağıdaki kelime
grupları şiirde hangi anlamı katıyor
demiş. Bakın, gölgeli yolda gezinme,
gönlüme misafir inme, kapısı kilitli,
mihrabı bomboş, bir başka düğün, denize
renginden bırak hediye. Bakın genel
anlamda baktığımızda denize renginden
bırak hediye. Yani öyle güzel renklerim
var ki denize hediye et, denize yansısın
orada da görelim diyor ama bana yaklaşma
hocam. Gönlüme misafir inme diyor.
Benimle işin olmasın diyor bir yandan
da. Yani bu kelime gruplarını genel
anlamda değerlendirdiğimizde baharın
güzelliği ama benden uzak dur vurgusu
hissediyoruz. Bu cepte kelimelerin
farklı anlamları. Şimdi bakın bu da
sorulma ihtimali marif noktasında çok
yüksek olan bir soru tarzı. Aşağıdaki
kelimeler şiirde gerçek anlamı dışında
mı kullanılmıştır? Neden? Nedeni çok
önemli. Bahar, bildiğimiz bahar, meyhane
biliyoruz tanımını. Mabet ibadet edilen
yer. Peymane ise kadeh arkadaşlar büyük
kadehler için kullanılan bir ifade.
Şimdi burada bahare eyvallah. Tamam
güzel. Yani bildiğimiz baharı anlatıyor
ama kişileştirerek anlatıyor. Gerçek
anlamından ufak ufak da uzaklaşıyor.
Meyhane, mabet, peymane gibi kelimeleri
ise bayağı bayağı gerçek anlamından
uzaklaştırarak veriyor. Peki neden genel
anlamda gerçek anlamdan uzaklaşıyoruz?
Çünkü bu metin bir şiir. Burada edebi
bir dil var. Edebi dilin kullanıldığı,
sanatın ön plana çıktığı, estetiğin
anlatıldığı şiirlerde gerçek anlam
kullanımı pek hoş olmaz. Olabilir mi?
Olabilir tabii. Gerçek anlamlı
kelimelerle oluşan didaktik şiirler yok
mu? var tabii ki ama genel anlamda
şiirlerde gerçek anlamdan uzaklaşıyoruz.
Mecazi vurgular. Neden? İmgeler olsun.
Yavum çağrışım olsun. Çağrışım hayal
gücü karşı tarafa okuyucuya geçsin diye.
Tamam. Neden? İşte bunun için
estetikliği çok daha iyi anlatabilmek,
sanatı çok daha iyi gösterebilmek için
nedeni bu. Yav geldim açık ve örtük
iletiye açık ileti direkt olarak vermek
istediği mesaj. Bahar güzel ama bana
yaklaşma. Bitti bu kadar. Peki örtük
ileti benim iç dünyamda bir karamsarlık
var. Bir acı var değil mi? Bir acı var
iç dünyamda. İçe kapalıyım ben. Aman
dikkat. İçine kapanık bir kişiyim.
Benden uzak dur hocam işte vermek
istediği örtük ileti bu. İç dünyamda bir
acı var hocam. Bunu söylüyor tam
anlamıyla bu. Y ahenge baktığım zamansa
bu şiirin zaten başlığında da var.
Sürekli bir gitbahar, gitbahar, gitbahar
vurguları bariz bir şekilde yani
tekrarlar bariz bir şekilde ahengi
sağlıyor. Aynı zamanda üç nokta
kullanımı da noktalama işaretleri de
ahengin önemli unsurları arasındadır. E
baktığım zaman aynı kelime tekrarı var.
Değil değil değil değil değil değil.
Bunlar da ahengi sağlayan, şiirin
gerçekten böyle hisli bir şekilde
okunmasını sağlayan unsurlar. Arkadaşlar
iyi güzel marif model bu sistemde
gidiyor. Ama nedir bunlar yani? İmge ne?
Çağrışım ne, sembol ne? Ne yapıyoruz
hocam biz? Hangi kavramları bilmemiz
lazım? Sözün inceliği temasında bilmemiz
gereken tüm kavramlar gelsin hocam. Bu
kitabınızda hemen daha ilk sayfalarda
var. Haberiniz olsun. Evet geldi
arkadaşlar notlarımız. Şimdi sözün
inceliği temasındayız. 9. sınıf Türk
Dili ve Edebiyatı dersindeyiz. Marif
modele göre anlatıyoruz. Bu şablonu
kullanmayı düşünüyorum arkadaşlar. Yıl
boyunca 9. sınıfla ilgili ne hazırlarsam
bu ve benzeri bir şablon renk tonu olsun
işte şekiller, kavramlar bu tarz bir şey
kullanmayı düşünüyorum. Benim hoşuma
gitti. Sizin de görüşlerinizi bekliyorum
arkadaşlar. Eğer sizin de hoşunuza
gittiyse mutlaka yorumlara yazın. Ben de
o yorumlara göre ya değiştireceğim ya da
bu şekilde devam edeceğim şablon
noktasında. Şimdi sözün inceliği
temasını ele alacağız. Evet hocam biz
bunu inceleyeceğiz. Güzel. Peki bu sözün
inceliği temasında biz hangi kavramları
bileceğiz? Neye bakacağız? Gelin
isterseniz satır satır her kavramı
beraber bir oturtalım. Bu kitabın ilk
ünitesinde kesinlikle almanız gereken
kavramlar bu liste. Tamam. Burayı bir
oturtalım. Açık ve örtük ileti yıllardır
anlatıyoruz. Ayrı ayrı videolar
çekeceğiz. uygulamalar yapacağız ama
gelin burada genel anlamda bir
öğrenelim. Metinde doğrudan söylenen
anlam yani doğrudan bize açık açık
verilen anlam açık iletiyi ifade ederken
ima edilen yazılmayan ama sezdirilen
anlamsa örtük ileti. Şimdi açık ileti
örtük ileti direkt olarak anlamı
veriyorsa açık ileti. Kapalı veriyorsa
örtük ileti nedir hocam örneğimiz? Haydi
örneğimiz gelsin mesela birazdan
göreceğiz ama yine de burada
vurgulayalım. Yani adam pencereden
dışarı izliyordu dediğin zaman adam
pencereden dışarı bakıyor. Açık
iletiyken alttan alta bir yalnızlık, bir
özlem, bir bekleyiş, bir hasret. Bu da
örtük iletim. Bu birazdan örneklerle
göreceğiz. Çağrışıma baktığım zaman bir
kelimenin veya ifadenin zihnimizde
uyandırdığı hatıralar, kavramlar. Şu
aşağıdaki sözleri ise sizlere
bırakıyorum arkadaşlar armağan olarak
ama zaman zaman ihtiyacımız olacak.
Mesela bakın okuyalım ki kelimeler bazen
başka dünyaların kapısını aralar. Evet.
bir kelimede ya bu kalem kalem ama bu
kalem derken bambaşka bir çağrışım,
bambaşka bir dünyaya seni götürebiliriz.
İşte çağrışımdan kastımız bu arkadaşlar.
Zihnimizi uyandırdı kalem dedim ama
benim aklıma bir sürü şey geldi. İlkokul
yıllarım geldi, lise hayatım geldi,
üniversite hayatım geldi gibi gibi.
Tamam. Çağrışımdan kastımız bu. Adeta
zincir görüntüsü. Bakın dikkat. Yani
birbirine bağlantılı şeyleri böyle
anımsatma gibi. Edebi dil arkadaşlar.
Sanatçının duygu ve düşüncelerini
estetik bir biçimde anlatma durumu.
Edebi dilden kastımız bu arkadaşlar.
Estetik bakın altını çizdiğimiz şeyler
önemli. Burası zihnimizde uyandırdığım
çağrışım cepte kalsın. Açık ve örtük
iledsee doğrudan ve dolaylı vurgularını
yaptık. Edebi dilde ise estetiklik var.
Lütfen cepte kalsın. Edebi dil bu. Daha
estetik, daha sanatlı bir şekilde
aktarma. Gerçekliğe baktığımız zamansa
adı üzerinde eserin yaşanmış hayattan,
toplumsal olaylardan veya gerçek
yaşamdan beslenmesi durumu. Yani bu
eserin gerçekliğine baktığımız zaman yok
gerçek hayatla çok da bağlantılı değil
gibi bir yorum istiyoruz yani. Tamam mı?
Ya da gerçek hayatın ta kendisi gibi.
Geldik günlük dile hocam. Günlük dilde
yine bu temada sözün inceliği temasında
bilmeniz gereken kavramlar arasında
günlük hayatta yani senin benim işte
mesela sen derste arada teneffüslerde
serviste arabada gelip giderken ne
konuşuyorsan tam da o sade ve anlaşılır
dil. Burada özellikle sade dil vurgusunu
yapmakta büyük fayda var arkadaşlar. Oba
geldim bir diğer noktaya hocam. Hayal
gücü ne? Hayal gücü bayağı bildiğiniz
imgeler dünyası. Hayal gücü ya hayal
kurma yetisi gibi aklınızda kalabilir.
İmge imge bizim için önemli. kelimelerle
yapılan zihinsel resimlerdir diyor. Çok
güzel bir tanım arkadaşlar. Okurun
zihninde görüntü, ses, koku, tat veya
dokunma hissi oluşturma. Bakın ne diyor
aşağıda. Edebi metin gözle değil hayal
gücüyle görülür. İmge bizim için önemli.
Mesela ne olsun? Hemen bir imge örneği
gelsin. Olay bitsin. Hayal gücünün
sınırları yok. Her şeyi ayredebilirsin
de imgeyi bir netleştirelim. Mesela
desem ki altın saçlı güneş. Ya bir anda
kafamda tık tık tık bir şeyler belirdi
ya da hüzünlü yağmur mesela. Hüzünlü
yağmurlar. Şimdi yağmur dedin eyvallah
da bende uyandırdığı birçok şey var.
Hüzünlü yağmur diyerek ne yaptı? İnsana
insana evet insani özellikler yükledi.
İnsana benzetti. Onu biraz daha böyle
dokunulabilir hale getirdi. Ya da adını
mıh gibi aklımda tutuyorum. Mıh
dediğimiz bu kalın büyük çiviler. Adını
mıh gibi aklında tutuyorum. Yani şimdi
adını aklında tutuyorum dese allak
bullak her şeyi anlaşılabilecek. Yani
soyut somut karışacak ortalık. Ama ben
ne yaptım? Adını mıh gibi bir çiviye
benzettim adeta böyle kalıcı hale
getirdim gibi bir imgelem kullandım.
İmge kullandım. cebinizde kalsın lütfen.
Kurmaca. Evet, gerçekte yok ama olma
ihtimali olabilir ama gerçekte genelde
olmayan yazarın hayal gücüyle şekillenen
şey romanlar, eserler vesaireler
kurmacaya örnek sembol doğrudan
söylenmek istemeini dolaylı olarak
anlatma, anlamı daha da derinleştirme
durumu. Şimdi hocam kurmaca ve sembolle
ilgili şöyle güzel akılta kalıcı bir
örnek verelim de iyice otursun hakkını
vererek gidelim. Şimdi Ahmet Hamdi
Tanpınar gel bir an aklıma bir
duraksadım orada hatırlayamadım. Ahmet
Hamdi Tanpınar'ın hocam saatleri
Ayarlama Enstitüsü diye bir kitabı var.
Bu kitap bir kurmaca. Çünkü saatleri
ayarlamak için bir enstitü kurulmamış.
Böyle bir şey yaşanmamış. Hayri İrdal
diye birisi yok. Doğal olarak saatleri
ayarlama enstitüsü bir kurmaca iken
oradaki saat bir semboldür. Saat sadece
zamanı ölçmek amacıyla kullanılan bir
araç olmaktan çıkmıştır. O eserde. Saat
orada doğu batı çatışmasını işte toplum
içindeki çatışmaları işte yozlaşmayı
değil mi? Aman dikkat bunları anlatır.
Eleştirel bir yaklaşımı anlatır. Cepte
kalsın. Bence kurmaca ve sembol bitti.
Net. Söz varlığı. Evet. Bir dildeki tüm
kelimeler ve bu kelimelerin zenginliği,
çeşitliliği tabii ki. Yani söz varlığına
baktığımız zaman bu romanda şu kadar
kelime kullanılmış, şu şu kelimeleri şu
anlamlarda kullanmış gibi bir açıklama
yapabiliriz. Sürükleyicilik, akıcılık
eserin okurdan merak uyandırması.
Arkadaşlar en önemli nokta bu aslında.
Sürükleyicilik ifadesi merak
uyandırmayla net bir şekilde karşımıza
gelebilir. Yaratıcılıksa şüphesiz ki
özgün bakış açısı. Tamam. Yaratıcılık
aklınızda böyle kalsın. E şüphesiz
bunlar cepte durmalı arkadaşlar. E o
zaman tamamdır hocam. 9. sınıf Marif
Model. İlk videomuzu attık. Bundan önce
videomuz vardı. Genel bir
bilgilendirmeydi ama ders anlatım
noktasında ilk videomuz tamamdır
arkadaşlar. Kanala abone olalım,
yorumlarımızı yağdıralım, beğeniler
yağsın, isteklerinizi yazın lütfen. Bu
şablonu da mutlaka değerlendirmenizi
istiyorum yorumlarda. Kendinize çok iyi
bakın. Yeni videolarda görüşmek üzere.
Kolay gelsin.